I do let's take the two conventions that
we've just experienced the Democratic
and Republican convention both both were
trying to send a message and I think a
subtle message not specifically
enunciated but subtext below the surface
message each trying to activate a
particular principle of influence that
we all respond to for the Democrats it
was the principle of consensus the fact
that the the final night speech was held
in a stadium of 80,000 people the
message was look at all of the people
who are on board with us it must be the
right thing to do
that message very clear if everybody's
doing something it's a shortcut
indication of what's the valid thing to
do right for the Republicans the message
of John McCain all the people who were
building up to his speech and all of the
first half of his speech was look what
this man has already given to us look at
the service that he has provided look at
the pain that he has experienced as a as
a patriot as a captive all those years
he's entitled to our support for what
he's done already there's a rule the
rule for reciprocation in all human
cultures that say we have to give back
to those who have given to us we have to
give back to those who have given to us
otherwise we're not good people if we
fail to do that so the subtext message
of the Republican convention I think is
look at what our man has done for you
you're in York you're obligated to pay
attention to his message at least
to do that much for him if not to
support him for what he's done the
Democratic message was look at all the
people who have supporting us it must be
the right thing for you to
there's good news about the extent to
which these principles apply in all
cultures and there's bad news too for
those of us who want to use them
effectively the good news is all six of
these principles the fundamental
principles of influence apply in all
human cultures the bad news is the
priorities associated with them are
different in cultures there was a great
study done at Stanford University in
connection with Citibank that has
offices all over the world these
researchers went to Citibank employees
in for prototypical cultures and they
said to these employees if one of your
colleagues came to you with a request
for help on a project that required
taking time energy even staffing away
from your own project under what
circumstances would you feel most
obligated to say yes and in the US the
answer came I would ask myself as this
requester done anything for me lately if
so I have to say yes that's the rule for
reciprocation in the Far East the answer
was different it was is this requester
connected to my group especially the
senior person in my group
this was deference to Authority out of
fealty to one's boss you have to say yes
to this person if he or she is connected
to your boss in the Mediterranean
cultures Spain the answer was is this
person connected to my friends
it wasn't fealty to your boss it was
loyalty to your friendship Network that
spurred the obligation I have to say yes
to this person and in Germany and the
Scandinavian countries the answer was
different according to the official
regulations and rules of this
organization and my sub
host:2 say yes so this was commitment
and consistency to a mission statement
to a set of of organizing principles and
people want to be consistent with that
the key is to recognize look it's not
that in Germany they don't care about
friendship of course they do it's not
that in New York they don't care about
authority of course they do but the
priorities the weights associated with
each of these principles will shift from
culture to culture
you know it's doing both it's it's
expediting the way through by by
segmenting the market more more in a
more detailed way but it's also causing
us to lose some humanity there was a
great study that was done MBA students
at Northwestern University and Stanford
University engaged in bargaining a
negotiation over internet right email
the most bloodless of all communication
mechanism and they were surprised to see
that when they engaged in this
negotiation by email in thirty percent
of the instances there was no successful
resolution the the negotiation was
stymied everybody lost they did a
follow-up where in instead of just
having them negotiate by email first
they had them send some information back
and forth about one another's personal
hobbies and where they went to school as
undergraduates where they grew up if
they'd been married you they have any
kids these kinds of things in other
words they personalized the exchange
before they got to business the way we
do in a face-to-face interaction and now
the same negotiation properties the same
simulation that they were working on
they only got 6% stymied negotiation so
you dropped from 30 to 6% by simply
bringing the flesh and blood back into
the exchange that the email process took
out so we can we can use technology for
very good purposes sometimes it
undercuts us but we can restore the
value of the human exchange by bringing
that back into the technology we use